welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Westworld season three is the
violent delight with violent ends that's
just as confusing as ever as I was
watching last night's episode from the
temporary blue dungeon mark - I ran into
the biggest what the moment spoiler
warning if you give oh what the a cameo
from HBO's other huge series Game of
Thrones in the form of drogue on the
dragon and Game of Thrones showrunners
David Benioff and DB Weiss what a
subversion of expectations now if you
manage not to turn into a Michael Scott
screaming gift at your TV this crossover
actually goes as everything goes this
season an additional layer deeper yeah
Westworld just linked three major
franchises in the same universe is this
indulgent fanservice or is it a master
bowl commentary on the cheap thrills of
pop culture a bit of both well I'm gonna
explain what this cameo means and
attempt to explain what it means for
this season of Westworld to quote the
Kryten verse island we just washed up on
and thanks to privacy comm for
sponsoring this episode if you sign up
now at privacy calm slash new rock stars
you can get 5 bucks today to use on any
purchase online ok Westworld season 3
has followed Bernard Lowe about three
months after having been brought into
the real world by Dolores and left to
work on a farm under the pseudonym
Armand Delgado
Bernard Lowe was an anagram for Arnold
Weber Armand de Delgado is an anagram
for damaged Arnold and as such Bernard
has been damaged corrupted switchin
among two personae a walking reflection
of Ford's bicameral mind perhaps the
voice of the God he's hearing is that of
Dolores or maybe the Wyatt identity or a
recreated host Arnold Weber that is not
Bernard just a different identity
Bernard has been set up as the fall guy
for the park massacre so he's on the run
in Episode two he returns to West world
an island in the South China Sea he
finds Ashley stubs confirmed to be a
host as many fans believed and he's
programmed to protect Bernard they're
trying to find Maeve Bernard runs
Diagnostics on himself and this takes
them to a lab beneath a different region
of the park medieval world essentially a
Ren Faire medieval times there's a host
plane the West world theme on a lute
should have been rains of castamere but
whatever among the hosts of medieval
world is it turns out drogon from Game
of Thrones and the two lab techs are
played by Benioff and Weiss waiting to
see if they get laid off she's
as soon as they get laid off give the
buyer what startup in Costa Rica taking
it that because to renew pieces men many
fans have long speculated that one of
the dela sparks could be Westeros world
and the West world creators we're to be
throwing them a bone by having their
medieval world populated by Game of
Thrones references similar to how rent
fairs of our world will sometimes evoke
things like from Game of Thrones and
Lord of the Rings and if you look even
more closely the background some are
saying the bearded host with the thick
hair looks a lot like the Hound from
Game of Thrones and the Castle art
behind Barnard looks a bit like Casterly
Rock the Lannister home of Game of
Thrones but the obvious joke here is
that Benioff and Weiss are these grunts
on the bottom floor of a violent
fictional world desensitized to
butchering beloved characters
originators of violent delights and
violent ends you could even read into
the idea that they're out of work
looking for their next gig and totally
okay with massacring the thing that
everyone loved for just an easy paycheck
but there is an even deeper layer to the
meta humour here Weiss mentions some
startup in Costa Rica the original West
world film was created by Michael
Crichton best known for Jurassic Park
story with the same violent delights
violent ends theme park concept as West
world Jurassic Park is located on the
fictional island of Isla Nublar
off the west coast of Costa Rica so the
Joker is implying that the startup in
Costa Rica could be engine John Hammonds
genetic research company in Jurassic
Park perhaps using this artificial
dragon as an attraction in their
dinosaur park
so what's world david ruins and Jurassic
Park all in one shared universe and you
thought Avengers endgame was the biggest
crossover event of all time it still
kind of is look we now live in an age of
streaming content and at home delivery
subscriptions and it's harder than ever
to keep up with the 10 different
subscription services that are just
waiting to charge us for something we
forgot to tell them we didn't want the
King II though it's managing the credit
card numbers that you give these folks
so that you can turn them on and off
when you need them to be on and off well
thanks to privacy con for sponsoring
this video
privacy lets you make online purchases
using virtual burner cards for each kind
of purchase instead of your real card
for everything this protects your
identity and bank information on the
internet and it lets you control the
limits on each virtual card so
for example I have set up an account for
privacy got linked my bank account and I
created a card specifically for my
monthly Netflix subscription payment
privacy will ding you with
lightning-fast precision if someone
tries to charge the card twice or if the
charge exceeds the amount you set for it
ha ha nice try Netflix Disney Plus has
me mostly covered for my infinity sorry
watch button yeah I'll be back when
witcheries no vendor can overcharge you
beyond the limit that you've set see
it's simple it's fast it's really just a
one click they also offer these
different plans a free plan that lets
you create up to 12 cards a month it's
also the pro plan where you can get 36
cards a month and 1% cash back on
purchases there's also a team's plan for
small businesses there's a privacy
Chrome extension where you can fill out
all of your card info to save time just
one click and all your details are
instantly entered just head to privacy
comm slash new rockstars and sign up for
an account and as a special treat for my
viewers new customers will automatically
get $5 to spend on your first purchase
for a limited time only if it's free
money just go to privacy comm slash new
rockstars and sign up now yeah I should
say that the start-up in Costa Rica is
likely not literally in Jin and Jurassic
Park since the Jurassic Park franchise
is owned by Universal Comcast and
westerlyn HBO are owned by Warner AT&T
these media companies hate each other as
much as the executives at Delos and
insight do so it's more of like Lea tip
of the head nod from one Crichton
universe to the other let's talk about
season 3 of West's world this is all
about a war a war deeper than the
fictional narrative loop of war world
that made finds herself in the war
between Dolores leading an army of
escaped West world hosts to infiltrate
the real world of mankind
it seems via the AI god tech that
operates his day to day life and launch
her next stage of evolution robots and
on the other side of this war corporate
figures using Maeve as their own AI
anomaly champion and the more of these
episodes we see I don't think the show
wants us to root for either side to win
this war they're both morally flawed
obviously mankind is corrupt but sort of
the overly violent machines they've
built
dolorous and Maeve are just the violent
ends of the violent delights of their
creators indeed the post-credits scene
after the ending the season 2 presented
some distant future with William and the
ruins of the dillos dowels it looks like
an abandoned battlefield after a war
with no Victor that's why I'm so excited
to see Aaron Paul as Caleb this season
caleb is being presented as a new
protect
and it's ready to break out of his loop
the same way Dolores was in season one
in fact the first episode framed him in
a loop with similar visuals as the horse
in the pilot episode caleb is a slave to
a narrative track laid out for him by
insights Rehoboam AI he must participate
in an automated therapy program to get
medical benefits for his mom an
automated voice denies him a job but
insists he was so close to getting it
even the rebellious RICO criminal gig
economy app that he uses is probably
sponsored by or at least permitted by
the system as a kind of Hamsterdam
release valve but notice that Caleb also
doesn't do personal jobs on the app he's
an underachiever with this point score
he defies a client when a gun is pointed
at his face
so while Caleb is like the loris and
that he wants to break the system he
differs from her and that he seeks to do
no harm
he helps Dolores at the end of episode 1
whereas remember Dolores at the end of
her first episode she gives a very
violent end to apply so was Liam's rich
douchey friend at the party right
is this real-world also a simulation
like the layers upon layers of
simulations that may found herself in
this episode maybe I hope not
personally I've had enough of that meta
from the matrix inception a good place
we've covered that territory but I do
think the idea that the show's real
world has a simulated feel operating
under so much clockwork that its
inhabitants feel like drones in a
fantasy is it for a found statement and
I want to see the war between Dolores
and Maeve's smash that clockwork but the
character I want to build the next world
is the one character on the show without
violent delights Caleb so including
Benioff and Weiss and Rogen here reminds
me of their controversial direction of
Game of Thrones in game Daenerys
Targaryen promised to break the wheel of
violence and then disappointedly crank
that same wheel as hard as she could
using this stupid dragon to burn
everything and leave us with a victor
that didn't all deserve the win so
hopefully West world is signaling here
that they have learned from that misstep
poking a bit of fun of the guys who sold
out their creation for pure violent
delights and instead putting at the
wheel of the morally pure hero from the
show with the perfect end game Breaking
Bad Jesse Pinkman Aaron Paul just to
suggest that they have something a bit
more profound in mind for West world's
final act comment down below with your
thoughts on this season of West's world
and this game of Thrones cross
follow me a da vos follow new rock stars
in subscribing the rock stars to
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]